à l'origine de la création de la zup de
mont pellier des considérations d'ordre
démographique économique
montpellier vient d'amorcer ce mouvement
d'accroissement de population qui se
soldera par le ruban bleu de l'expansion
démographique la ville étouffe dans son
cadre urbain il faut élargir le
périmètre de l'agglomération
il faut construire et la municipalité
fois l'initiative de créer une société
d'économie mixte à qui elle confie la
réalisation du projet le premier coup de
bulldozer à la paillade remonte en
janvier 1960 et 1964 que 2 le 15 avril
1967 les premiers logements ont été
livrés pour premiers habitants la
période et ce qui est à signaler je
crois ce qui est très important c'est
qu'à cette même date
exister le groupe scolaire qui
fonctionnait à ce moment là et le
premier autobus de liaison entre la
pagaille et la vie
progressivement la vie s'organise ce qui
n'était qu'un chantier devient une vraie
ville avec ses rues son centre
commercial c'est avenue
depuis la construction des premiers
immeubles la population de la paillade
n'a cessé de croître en 1967 au terme de
la première tranche des travaux
dix mille habitants 4700 logements et
bientôt plus du double
vingt mille habitants la suite
plus de 4000 logements terminés et que
la cadence de construction évoluent dans
des conditions favorables même si la
commercialisation c'est un petit peu
ralenti il suffisait d'ailleurs pour
s'en rendre compte de son évolution et
du fait qu'il s'agit des chantiers
permanents la zone sud
nous pensons que ce sera terminé d'ici
un an et demi ou deux ans la zone
nord-est et terminer pratiquement plat
zone nord ouest va démarrer et la zone
centrale
je m'entraîne actuellement de d'étudier
le le plan masse c'est dire que sans
vouloir bien entendu faire des
pronostics cela pourrait peut-être un
peu hasardeux nous pouvons considérer
que d'ici cinq ans les 1500 logements et
les 35000 habitants qui doivent les
occuper sur route en place
la paillade c'est d'abord une
harmonieuse répartition des immeubles
collectifs et des habitations
individuelles
en fait la paillade je crois que c'est
avant tout est ce qu'on a voulu surtout
à révérer réalisé avant tout c'est un
quartier de montpellier comme les autres
quartiers de montpellier je peux dire
quand même au passage que je crois est à
mon sens c'est actuellement le quartier
de montpellier mieux équiper les
équipements sportifs comme le complexe
nautique et les équipements culturels
ont suivi la progression de la cité
k
nous avons maintenant adopter une
vitesse de croisière un ton volontaire
d'ailleurs pour permettront aux
équipements collectifs écoles centres
sociaux qui plan culturel équipements
culturels sportifs suivent également la
cadence de construction
pour l'avenir je voudrais ajouter
d'ailleurs à cet égard que si les
collectivités la société d'équipements
et la ville et l'état
certaines circonstances peuvent apporter
et apporte effectivement leur concours
matériel sous forme de réalisation
d'équipements cette ville qui en fait un
quartier de mon pays et qui doit rester
un quartier de montpellier ne vivra que
tout autant que ses habitants voudront
elles vivent
il y a dix ans les détracteurs du projet
mettait en avant sa trop grande ampleur
une ville de 35 mille habitants
disait-il mais qui donc ira y habiter la
réponse est là aujourd'hui une cité
nouvelle
l'une des plus peuplées de l'hérault
intégrés au décor bien ancré dans la
réalité et dont l'avenir est étroitement
lié à celui de montpellier
à